hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jessie today I want to show you a
pull request that was made that fixed
the little issue that we had yesterday
at the end of the stream and they were
going to work with that new component
that we made so we have a new component
a new query and a new way to do routes
that'll save us from having to make so
many different components and queries so
we're gonna do a few a few routes with
that and it should work right if it
works once then it should work with the
other ones but you know we'll just we'll
make sure and we'll build some of those
out we'll see how we look and I want to
share with you kind of the the next
stage of this that probably won't work
on until later on in the year but it'd
be good to you know just get everybody
on board and see what you all think
about it so I just had a meeting this
morning where we discussed some things
for the future of this website that's
not even done yet but we're already
thinking about more so everybody see
some of you in the live chat ok all
right hard should see are good so
Harshit is the one that actually made
the pull request so I'm glad that
Harshit is here and that way if I mess
things up what I'm trying to describe
what he did he can let me know I have n
rock running I'm gonna paste that into
the live chat now and I may have to
paste it again after a while if we get
some more viewers it looks like I'm I
didn't get the stream scheduled till a
little bit later today so not everyone
you may have gotten the notification cuz
I'm seeing in the analytics there's not
too many people in here yet and we're
missing some people that are usually
here but it looks like at least some of
you're getting on
the N Grogg server that if you're not
familiar with n grog that link will
allow you to see on in your browser what
I have here running locally on my
computer
so let's get started
and I am going to first go over that
that pull request that I was telling you
about so you can see this is what we're
trying to get to display yesterday and
it is displaying properly now so here's
how it was done and you can check out
these pull requests requests in more
depth in the repo so if you check the
link in the description for this github
rebuild you go in there and you look at
the latest closed pull requests the last
two that I closed were both from Harshit
so I believe it was whatever the second
to the last one was that was the one
let's see
Alexi I see your question I'll get to it
in just in just a minute all right where
we have page okay so this is the right
component so you can still see the old
way that we were doing queries and some
of the other components if you if you
want to go back and check that out you
can but here's the latest so we upgraded
to the beta version of Apollo to this
react Apollo sorry I'm just getting
myself familiar with what we did so
obviously we're importing query now
which we didn't we didn't have before
and some of this we we had already
worked on before the stream ended
yesterday but so we're bringing in query
and then we're using this query
component down here so we're calling
page query
all right which we made here right so
here's our page query component and we
can take a variable that's a type in a
variable list of name all right so we're
passing it this variable type and that
just means the the post type so we have
all these different custom post types
running in WordPress and we have graph
QL the WP graph QL plug-in running so we
want to get the right post type and
that's what we pass in here and then we
pass in the variables and as name we're
passing in the ID as well and that will
get a certain post of that particular
post type and then heart should also you
know has in here you know some loading
something to display if there's an error
which is awesome and if we do get the
data back then we just you know display
it as you know we are normally going for
most of the components we're just
displaying the the base content here and
you see now we have none of the stuff
down the bottom that we did have all of
its moved up in here I think this is
really nice this is obviously coming
from doing it the other way to this way
it looks a little odd to me because I
learned the other way first but trying
to just think of this more objectively
here I think the query component is is
it's much more obvious what's going on
here if maybe it's just me you all let
me know what you think but I I kind of I
really like it it's I mean we have a
query component and we're making a query
and then we're getting we're getting the
result and we're doing something with
that I don't know that makes sense to me
so anyway that's really cool essentially
we have a pretty simple component here
but I suppose if you needed to fill in
different places with with data
you would just add them all in here so
the query and it essentially would be
kind of a wrapper around your whole
component in this case we don't really
need that for everything although you
know potentially we'll see maybe you
know depending on what we do later on
with the site we might need something
like that but anyway I like it I really
like that and yeah cool good job I
should uh I should also did a few other
things so if you want to check that out
you know go ahead in the in the repo I
keep forgetting that is called Arriba so
that I said it already a three times and
every time I was like um repo okay let's
see let me go back to the live chat now
before we get started with coding all
right so Alexia had a question about the
style how did you style the underline in
the text field on the search and so the
text field research this would be
easiest just to see so when let's see if
we can't focus yeah I believe that's it
no it's not on this element it's on this
one
mmm it's not gonna show
I don't know which element it's on so
one of these elements has I believe it's
a it's the bottom border and how I can't
even remember sorry sorry Alexi decided
it's not the whole a lie
hmm anyway I'm maybe gonna have to check
that out
Oh harsh it's says it's a material I
component oh you know what our [ __ ] yeah
yeah for some reason I was thinking of
the old what's it called materialized I
was thinking the old materialized
components and how we did it with that
yeah so but basic if you wanted to do
this on your own with CSS you could do
this and create an underline and then
just add I mean we see that's probably
what 1 or 2 pixels I mean it's really
thin and then just on focus you would
have the color change so I have done
that before with just plain CSS you know
if if I need to work on something where
I can't import like materialized or
material UI then that's usually how I do
it it's not exactly the effect so let me
zoom in here and show so if you decide
to do just the plain CSS underline it's
nice you don't have to use any
JavaScript but you don't get exactly the
same effect so if you notice here it's
very subtle and fast but it spreads from
the interior to the sides even when we
when we click out of it you see it comes
back in so it's a little bit more
involved than just changing it right and
and that's closer I believe it's been a
while since I've looked at the material
design documentation but I believe that
this is closer to the way it is supposed
to be so but it's it's almost I mean it
would take somebody who really paid
attention to that kind of thing to
notice the difference if you were to
just put the underline there anyway so
hopefully that at least cleared up some
of how we did that
oh okay was it Tim says he styled the
before of the search container now
anyway yeah in this case its use the the
materialized component is being used so
I'm not exactly sure how that is
happening but I do know how you can get
a similar effect with the CSS all right
cool John Hanson said that the new way
that
Harshit setup here is is a lot cleaner
so yeah I definitely agree
Harshad also says that this is bleeding
edge and he had to set up a babble
plugin to get this to work okay so yeah
thank you for mentioning that yes so
since this is the the beta version right
so it's not
I guess normally you you would want to
use stable versions for something in
production I'm okay with this uh number
one like we still have over a month
until we were launching this so I mean
it's possible that this stuff could get
moved over into a stable release before
then but also I'm I don't know I'm a
little bit more open to using you know
the beta version of things so I I guess
it'll I guess it'll work out I hope
it'll work out but I I think we've done
it before on other projects so I'm I'm
okay with it obviously you know we're
just gonna keep you know we're gonna
test everything and make sure that that
it all works but hopefully it all works
I really like this solution and let's
let's get started I want to list or
might need new batteries in my trackpad
I'm just having weird issues right now
with my trackpad so sorry if I seem
distracted that's that's what's
distracting me I'm trying to test out my
trackpad it just seems like it just
keeps cutting out but I'm not getting a
low battery warning or anything yeah
it's it's showing the battery this being
fun that's just really odd
okay
well let's get started then and work
with this let me remember to set my
timer this time I'm gonna pull it over
under this screen so y'all can see it as
well and we're gonna set this for 25
minutes I'm gonna work on this and then
we'll take a break
I'll go back to the live chat I don't
know we may only do one one coding
session today I still have a lot of data
to transfer over and it seems like now
that we have this component all worked
out it's going to just be a lot of
repetitive things so may not be the it
may not be interesting enough to do a
lot of coding with so maybe we'll spend
more time on the question and answer
today we'll just see how it goes I mean
this is all assuming that I don't have
errors or anything which when does that
ever happen okay let's see what we need
well we're gonna be working mainly I
suppose in our server dot J's file today
okay by the way if you do clone this
repository if you've already cloned it
make sure when you pull in changes that
you do install the new dependencies so
we've updated packages yesterday and
Harshit has added things in and made
some changes to to babble so things will
not work right unless you do an NPM
install or just yarn so make sure you do
that and restart the server if you
already have it running all right so
let's go right here oh yeah is this the
one I want to find the one that we just
use that word was it about yeah so we're
gonna use this same one as is almost you
know like a template
and let's go in here and set up some
more post types so on my other screen
I'm gonna check our WordPress
installation just to see you what post
types I have created and I don't think
that I've imported all the data for all
these types we'll go ahead and make the
routes anyway you know we need to make
them at some point so may as well make
them now I do have a route that is
okay so we have a page for our chapel so
we do it's a Catholic University so we
have a chapel on campus and there's a
lot of stuff that goes on there so we
have a whole set of pages just for the
chapel and all the things that that go
on there so I believe about pages yeah
it'll be chapel pages that should be the
correct type Chapel ID page all right
wonderful and I guess I can check see if
we have data over here oh I didn't
actually pull in those pages yet so
we're not gonna be able to test that so
let's move on let me find one that I
know I did update afore okay great so we
also have academics pages and I would I
need to start thinking about and if
anybody has ideas let me know ways to
clean this up
this server dodged ass is getting big I
mean I believe we've done more in server
j/s when we handle some you know like
file uploads and different things so
it's gotten messier than this before but
I think that we can definitely clean it
up so we talked about it before but it's
getting to the point now where we could
probably benefit from cleaning it up so
let's change chapel to academics and now
I think we can't test this so let me
just get the slug of one of these and if
any of you want to see like what I'm
doing in WordPress on my other screen
let me know really I'm just I'm just
copying and pasting some stuff so it's
not a big deal but I've definitely
willing to put it over on my screen if
if you all think it would be worth it to
see so when we do this we do need to
restart the server so let me do that now
I thought we set it up somewhere in some
project to where we it would
automatically restart the server for us
if we saved off to go back and check out
you know maybe some of the package.json
files in previous projects because I
don't remember exactly which one it was
but since we're doing so many changes to
our server
jas file then maybe it might save some
time and be worth it for now though
let's test this out so we're going to do
academics slash rigor the Austria
courses offered page no nothing all
right well it's it's actually really
cool that we didn't get an error I like
that let's see if I spelled everything
correctly academics pages academic okay
that is the slug Austria course is
offered
I wonder
mr. double checking to see if maybe
there was some data and for some reason
it's not being displayed yeah it's not
being offered okay so what's the problem
here or I'm I mean what did I say
offered us it's not being being shown
something's wrong
let's figure this I think we have a CSS
issue and our data is actually coming
through I'm really glad that I I decided
to look at that so if you remember when
we were bringing in the state and we
were keeping all of the markup as is
from the old database because that was
going to give us a huge advantage in
speed we don't want to keep the markup
like that ideally you know we would
clean it all up at some point but that
can be done later after we launch
unfortunately sometimes we have
weirdness like this that we have to deal
with where contents just not displaying
properly
I think I setup all right so the way I
handle stuff like this and other
components is either I change the CSS
well or both but or I've set up like a
little function that just changes the
what did we do we end up doing a regular
expression right I think hard should you
helped out with that so that was we did
we did a regular expression that matched
up what we were looking for and then
changed it so in this case like we don't
want another title tag so we would
change this to some sort of age tag in
fact let's try to do that now see if we
can get something to show up let's try
an h2 for this alright we're still
getting nothing let's see that's really
weird what's going on display:none
all right the root is set to
display:none okay I see for some reason
I was setting route to display:none for
our news CSS that's really weird all
right so okay so we do have something
right we've changed this to an h2 so we
have our tabs shift tab content okay and
more titles yeah this definitely needs
some work
Wow
Wow okay
yeah this content needs cleaned up for
sure let me look at some other content
within the same post type if it's
something that's consistent throughout
then we'll find a way to deal with deal
with it a lot if it's just something
that's happening for this one piece of
content then that'll be something that
we can manually change or have someone
else manually change it alright let's
see I saw and and Andres let me know if
I'm pronouncing that wrong but it looks
like Andres says hi I love your live
change they're awesome thanks for saying
I really appreciate that
and there was an exclamation point at
the end I probably didn't sound too
excited when I say it but it was there
but anyway thank you so much for
watching and saying that all right let
me find another piece of content here
alright let's check out the content for
online programs
all right cool so the online programs
content is coming through and doesn't
look too bad I mean I I definitely don't
want to leave it just like this but this
is not that bad all right great cool so
maybe I'll have to take a look more at
the structure some of this content oh
sorry that's a big yawn wow it's like
three days in a row now I've just been
getting tired right at this point in the
day and yawning alright so yeah I'm
gonna just I'm gonna need to take a look
at this actually this might be a good
task for someone else to do like a
student worker I'm just I'm not trying
to push off on my stuff on the student
workers but at this point I need to make
sure I use my time you know very wisely
to get everything done before launch so
if there's some tasks that you know
seems like it wouldn't take very much
you know special knowledge of web
development to do then that's a test
that I could easily you know give to to
anyone else who can do you know basic
kind of data entry work okay so that
essentially works right we're in the
sense that we've set up a route and it's
pulling in the data it's utilizing our
page component and our page query that's
what we wanted so let's check out our
another post say we have admissions
pages now which we have no content for
but I can at least make the route and
we've confirmed that this route does
actually work now so we've got it to
work with about pages and we got to work
with academics pages
so we should be able to use the same
pattern admissions pages and so my kind
of strategy for organizing this content
now is to go by I guess like I don't
even know if it's Department it's not
exactly a department but I'm trying to
group things by kind of like larger I
you could say Department right
I mean academics I guess isn't but like
chapel ministries I guess is what we
call that department here and then we do
have an admissions department so we'll
have we have certainly faculty
departments but even within like the
University of their staff departments so
we're gonna have one for Human Resources
so actually I could probably do that as
well so we'll have Human Resources which
I believe just is using HR so I think
we're just gonna keep the HR and then
that way all the URLs will match up
that's good Human Resources and we may
have some of these already pulled in let
me double check see if we come over oh
cool we do have some so let's try we
have one piece of content and the slug
is strategic approach so let's see if
that works we're gonna have to restart
our server again unfortunately I saw her
she's putting some things in the lab
chat about using node Mon to auto
restart the server so that's a that
that's what we were using before so I
thought that was it but I wasn't sure
sometimes when I think something is the
thing I just don't say it for two
reasons one better just stay quiet than
to look like a fool on a live stream
also if I say it then it's gonna be in
your mind and if I say the wrong thing
then I will possibly have misled some of
you so I appreciate when I get that
verification from from some of you in
the live chat alright so let's try HR
strategic approach yay all right so that
works awesome and this is so much faster
so I if you haven't watched the last
like we go to extremes remember we work
for each one of these we would make so
for every single one that we've just
done here which we've done four we would
have made not only this but also a new
component and a new query so really
really cool we've already just I mean so
much time being saved here it looks like
our shirt says there's some other stuff
that might save a ton of time dude say
Plus pay you stand thinking of a baby
okay so harsh it's thinking of a way to
save some time very cool all right cool
let me know more of what you're thinking
because I'm not thinking server do I get
and then type ID all right let me know
more of what you're thinking there
i D
aha Nietzsche says now go to those pages
on the live site get that endorphin hit
because it loads so much faster yeah
let's do that because that is going to
be really fun so let's go to HR
strategic approach so we've just gone
through it here you saw how fast that
was Franciscan dot edu slash oh that was
really fast for this site but still just
can't compare with this now obviously
it's running locally but still still so
much faster awesome and I think
ultimately you know it looks nicer to
you know even just the basics that we've
done here it just appears more readable
to me all right cool Harshit says we can
make a universal route for this I saw
repetitive pattern alright that's that's
cool I'm I'm definitely up for you know
cutting this down even more let's see
let me let's look did I do route for
campus security yet no I didn't and I
don't have the content migrated over for
that either so it's not really a big
deal we can do that route but I'm really
interested though and seeing how we can
how we can make this a little easier so
oh cool javascript is here hey how's it
going thanks for watching and
let's see alright hard saying can I use
teletype yet let me open at him and see
if I installed teller site I thought I
had it installed when he first came out
obviously I'll probably need to update
it if that's the case
I guess I don't have to tell the type
installed
all right so teletypes installing now on
my other screen we'll see how long that
takes
oh cool that was really fast
see
all right I'm not learn more okay they
have a link to learn more about how to
do this
alright let me pull over add them on to
my other screen and so everyone can see
it so I just installed that and let's
open up a project folder let's projects
and Franciscan site is that it yeah this
is it yes let's do this
and let's see we should have a new icon
somewhere yeah there we go
this is just a simple new Asus and only
if you know join your photo by selling
your project maybe I should do this on
my other screen because I think I'm
gonna get a portal ID and I don't want
everybody on the project
alright looks like I have to login and
tell us I thought I
all right Harshit I'm sending you my my
code or whatever on Twitter all right
there we go
it's cents and let's open this up our
server daddy is
all right so hopefully that'll work for
what what hards trying to do here let me
know I really don't know how this is
supposed to work so maybe we'll see
we'll see our [ __ ] when he starts to
work on this I'm not sure until then I
think my time is almost up so I'm gonna
go back to the we're gonna put that
timer oh yes I'm just almost up so let
me go to the live chat now and I'll go
back over here in case the hard [ __ ]
starts doing something with this all
area I can see a little picture of our
[ __ ] very cool so I'm gonna go to the
live chat and answer some questions and
then maybe we'll be able to see what's
going on here
cool Hey all right awesome so this is
hard [ __ ] typing right now this is
really cool it's the first time I've
used teletype with Adam so this is like
Google Docs style coding I suppose
so let's yeah let's just watch this
while I out scroll through and see if
there's any questions I can answer
okay cool Harshad I see what you'd said
about no daman earlier that's cool maybe
I ought to get that set up
Oh an ETS see you asked earlier about
that graph QL issue yeah check out
Harshit submitted some pool requests one
of them fix that issue so if you want to
see the code for it you can check that
out I went over it briefly at the
beginning so if you you know catch the
recording of this you might be able to
see that all right and harsh it says
it's PR 67 so pool request 67 all right
so let's check until our shirts made a
universal route here so we're doing a
server dot get and then we have type and
ID the render cache page type and then
we're also passing in the type here
you know what a hard [ __ ] this is will
this work with everything this won't
work with everything
yeah actually so this will only work
with certain types right so it's still
gonna save us some time but it won't
work all the time so like for instance
it wouldn't work with this human
resources one right so we were passed
we're one of the route HR but then the
type is actually human resources but
with here it would be HR up here and
then HR pages down here so I mean I if I
really
it's possible that maybe I could try to
make a lot of things fit into this so we
could use it more like I could go back
and change the WordPress plug-in let's
see so soon for HR I place it above if
it will come first Express will render
and ignore this oh yeah yeah that's what
I was thinking so that's we can
definitely use this we just have to make
sure that it's it comes last so this
would work let's see what we can get rid
of we could get rid of admissions
academics chapel about so let's get rid
of these right now and now let me
restart the server we'll just test it I
mean it should work but always get the
test
all right that should still work right
no no did I didn't flip the order right
wait did I get rid of HR - I didn't
sorry about that
got rid of too much all right now let's
restart this and start a backup good
thing I checked that and not just
assumed that it would work I was
planning on using that pattern of saying
like like academics pages admissions
pages for a lot of the other different
post types that I have to make so that
it should automatically work for a lot
of these which is really awesome alright
so let's try let's just hit the back
button and just make sure that these are
working so that's academics so that's
now using this so that just came through
here right because we're not actually
saying academics anywhere that came
through here and it worked properly
awesome and we go back another one only
this was the one that had problems like
the date is there but there's just some
issues with its displaying cool our
about page still works so you can see we
had taken out the about route there so
it's hitting this one awesome alright
that's really awesome
so unfortunately because of just the
because we have to match up how the URLs
are on the current site we're not going
to be able to use this for everything
there's just too much variety and how
how that you know came through I mean
it's I said I'm going to keep in mind
this from now on and when I make new
post types and
things in I'll try to follow the same
pattern so it works for as many things
as I can make it work for maybe I could
probably switch up some things like HR
the only thing that I it's gonna be a
problem are hyphenated thing so if
things are hyphenated for instance like
campus - security and hyphenated in the
URL
I can't bring even if I were to change
the post site to campus security pages
it would still be campus - security and
I can't pass in a hyphenated thing this
it makes an error with the WPA graph QL
plug-in so it has to be camelcase
so those are the only ones that
absolutely won't work for this almost
everything else could work with the
exception of I mean I guess we have
minor but we don't have pages so some of
them just won't make sense to put pages
on the end but we could potentially just
to take advantage of using this for now
I'm not gonna worry about changing what
we've already done because that's that's
just going to be extra work we don't
need to do it right now we can do it
after the site launches or if we have
time and we finish everything else but
from now on I'm going to try to use this
so thank you very much harsher since I
ended up doing coding on my question
time I'm going to go back to the live
chat now and try to answer these
questions
okay Nikki says might need some
translation layer between the the type
and the string passed into rendering
cache
next to type so yeah this that's right
actually yeah why didn't I just think
about that yeah we could do something
where if there's a - it changes it and
I'm sure there's a way that we could
also capitalize you know the the second
word as well okay so X that is possible
so something hyphenated it that's not
really going to mess us up thanks for
bringing that up Nikki I'm it actually
seems like yeah obviously we can
manipulate strings in JavaScript like
now that you say that I what was I
thinking but I really that thing is a
good idea
let's see
I lost my place in the labs how do you
say I'll see you hey how's it going
peter says I've been trying to follow
along as much as possible but missed a
lot of the beginning streams what server
dodge is okay so our server Jas file is
we're using node.js which is JavaScript
running on the server side sorry if you
know all this I'm just like that's
explaining as if you know it's it's
somebody that doesn't know everything
so please don't take it personally so
it's JavaScript burning on the server so
right now what we're doing is we're
listening for requests and then we're
doing something based on that so if we
get a get request to a certain route
we're gonna do something and what we're
doing here is we're actually we're
caching that request but and then we're
rendering it or reverse that right but
we're sending it to the component that's
the page component so page Jas and then
we're sending some variables so we're
sending the ID which is passing here and
we're sending the string human resources
we actually worked on another way to do
this that's that's a better way here
this one's a little bit easier though
for me to explain because they're less
less variables going on so that's all
we're really doing in this section of
our server dot J's file we're just
making sure that when a user comes to
the site to a certain URL the right
components with the right information
get sent back to that user so the right
thing renders on the screen let me know
if that explanation was okay if you need
me to explain some more
all right rook says make a translation
object pull the corresponding value from
the key and pass that into the type and
rendering cache then everything fits in
the universal route do you use a you do
use a translation object though ok harsh
it says this will not hurt you just have
to follow a post type naming convention
nikki says you can make it default to
the way it's working now by using a
logical or operator just thinking out
loud here it will work right our search
that says make route for that one that
also fits in that method I fan it was ok
cool so Nikki and Harshit basically are
still talking about these routes
essentially there is a better way to do
all this to cut down on the total amount
of routes so again I'm gonna say and I
think I've seen a lot is before I said
this before but I'm gonna say for now
everything that's there is gonna stay
there everything new that we add on I'm
gonna try to fit either into this route
or into another like Universal route so
it's Universal lish right so it doesn't
work everywhere worried so either gonna
do that or we're gonna have some site
like nikki was saying of translation so
that basically the type that gets fast
in here gets transformed before it gets
passed in here
okay I should I see what you're saying
about the JavaScript AF stuff yeah oh um
I'll make you a maintainer and you can
like message me about that too on
Twitter or whatever and we can work all
that out Peter says okay cool I
definitely need to jump into some nodejs
soon currently doing code Academy Perl
intensive course for building web apps
using react so I would guess node would
be good to learn next yeah definitely I
really like using node with react I know
you can use react with with other stuff
but node just seems so natural since
you're already using javascript like I
don't know I figured like why not use
full stack JavaScript if you're making
web apps right like no sense bringing in
another language and I to me that just
complicates things more unless there's
some really good reason why you ought to
use another language then just keep it
simple with just one so I think Note is
great
okay all right well I've gotten to the
bottom of the live chat here and so I
know we only really did one like coding
session but we're already coming up on
an hour of the live stream so I kind of
went over into the little longer than a
25-minute session so I think I'm gonna
wrap things up here on Hill says how can
I help with the JavaScript AF repo okay
I'm gonna say this I don't want to spend
too much time talking about the
JavaScript AF thing here because it's
not like well number one I am I'm at
work and the JavaScript out AF is a
side-project thing but the other thing
is to like free code camp is you know
nonprofit so I don't want to bring
something in that potentially will end
up being for-profit into here so anybody
that's interested in JavaScript AF check
out my github so Jesse or Y go I think
it's my github check it out you can
bring up issues and things in there and
we can just discuss it if we get a lot
of people involved maybe we can find out
a better way to communicate but I think
for now github issues will work fine so
right now I have two repos Java scripts
- AF is one for the front end and then
we add JavaScript AF API which I don't
think we're going to be using for
back-end stuff because I think we're
gonna use firebase so we may just be
using the one so you know go ahead and
check out the repo open an issue if you
if you have questions or if you just
want to let me know like hey I want to
work on this that's cool and see ya
right now it's really bare but we will
be doing some things so basically
something that would be very helpful
right now is JavaScript er has built out
like front-end all the design but it's
not all react if I'd yet right so that
needs to be changed into react
components on the repository that
on my my github profile so my account so
maybe we could get something going maybe
I'll make an issue or something with all
the relevant information of you know
bringing things over and then if you
would like to help you can just pick
some piece of the UI to turn it into a
component and we'll I guess we'll go
from there
so let's see I think that's it
alright okay cool so I had some other
things come up in the live chat but it's
all JavaScript AF things so they said
just message me on Twitter or something
about that
or put it in the issues in the repo C
near F says hello I am new to JavaScript
I want to learn JavaScript from scratch
and want to clear all fundamentals any
suggestions you can check out well free
code camp their curriculum will help
their exercises so free code camp org if
you like books there's a book series
called you don't know J s and you can
read it for free on github so if you
just search you don't know J ass github
it'll be probably the first thing that
comes up you could read through those
otherwise if you prefer videos I mean
there are a ton of good videos but in
particular Bo has a whole series of
introductory JavaScript and more
advanced JavaScript videos here on the
free code camp channel so you know check
check those out if you can of course
there's I'm sure there's probably an
audiobook version of you don't know Jay
s as well if you prefer that but between
those resources that'll be a good
foundation for you so if anyone else has
any suggestions please put them in the
live chat there for Fournier F
oh cool
hardships unlike using style components
sneaky says definitely want to learn
about style components are definitely
gonna help awesome
I heard saying we can't use jQuery yeah
yeah we don't want to use jQuery for
reacts for sure
okay I'm gonna wrap things up here if we
want to continue the JavaScript to have
conversations somewhere else that's cool
maybe I'll open some issues on github
just to get everything straight and
trying like we can Rosa can we talk we
do have the free code camp slack that
we've created for the live chats I
haven't actually checked into that slack
channel in a while but we can also start
a channel on there and talk about it
more if you want so anyway let me know
you know you all know how to get ahold
of me all my social media stuff is out
there so if anybody's interested the
project let me know somehow and we'll
get it Harshit says a gator room would
be good
yeah Gator room would be great as well
so yeah we'll figure out some some
better way of talking about this and
then where we can all talk you know
that's a group I think would be good all
right so I'm gonna wrap things up for
today I'll be back tomorrow and I'm not
sure what we'll be working on I'll try
to think of something more exciting than
just doing the same thing here and maybe
maybe we can do some more work on the
homepage and get that nicer I'd love to
get that to a point where it really
looks good we can start showing it off
to people all right cool until then have
a great day